Muhammad hijab continues to speak from
pulpits to find it humorous to perform
marriages over WhatsApp and a McDonald's
meal as the Mahar.
Hi, can I get a happy meal for a girl?
What type of happy meal?
Uh, chicken nugget.
What sausage do you have? Uh, do you
have the six piece? Say it again. Do you
have the six piece? Six piece. Yeah.
Yep. That's what I one for each year. If
you look just at the Quran, you will get
the indication that you can have sex
intercourse with a 5-year-old. Anything
else for you? Uh, no. That covers my
fiance. Uh, one second. One second. The
Quran doesn't
say doesn't say anywhere in the Quran
that the woman has to be published. Is
that all?
Can I get a mcm?
Oh, what? Uh, mcm with extra muta.
You said a mc blenda. Mcmah. I'm not
sure what that is. Oh, is the menu
different from Europe? Yeah. Oh, okay.
Yeah. Yeah. That's the main thing in the
UK. In
Islam, you need a man and a woman to get
married. All I need is two witnesses.
And I also need a mah, which is a dowry.
Once these three things are there,
that's it. That's actually all it takes
to get married in Islam. That could take
10 seconds. It could take literally one.
I've gotten people married in 1 minute
and 60 seconds cuz I was busy. Someone
comes to the office and say, "Listen, I
need to get married this and that." Say,
"Listen, I need to go to the toilet."
So, this is going to have to be a quick
one, you know. Say 1 2 3. Okay. Husband
and wife. I've even gotten people
married on WhatsApp. I was Yeah. driving
and this guy, he called me. He said,
"Look, I'm going to commit haram." He
goes, "I've got two uh witnesses ready
on this WhatsApp group. Can I add you
and you do the thing?" So, I brought
them in. I said to the the woman, I said
to her, "Listen, this guy's probably
going to leave you. I know this
guy." No. you know, she said, "I don't
mind. I don't care." You know, whatever.
You know, and I said, "What's the mah?"
And the guy said, "You don't want to
hear this one." This is before
McDonald's was on the boycott list. He
goes, "I'm going to give her a meal in
it happened." And he he did in fact uh
divorce her, unfortunately. But I said,
"I told you so." And that was it. But
that's how easy marriage is in Islam.
What would you like? Oh, they don't have
the zoot either. The zoot is like French
fry with everything piled on top of it.
But most of the the big names of da have
at least done polygamy once. Most of
them if not say like every every person
that you can think of
like almost names and and people you
wouldn't expect. Would that be all that
and
uh a shake?
I need a shake. What's that shake?
uh like Ronald McDonald shake Ronald
McDonald to do the muta. We don't have
the people who the women who take it the
best are the revert sisters. From my
experience of observing the situation,
you know,
I've all
Yeah, that's it. Thanks. Okay. Okay,
come around to the first one.
I'm loving
muted on that. You proud on that. You on
that. You just back fine on me. You on
that. You on that. You on that. You just
back fine on me. This is a power of a
religion. There's a reason to it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.